I've always thought Grimace was a creepy
character as is but as we look back in
time it gets even worse the original
commercial portrayed Grimace as a Dopey
but crazed adct living in a cave with
four arms however this was actually a
less scary version of Grimace than what
they had originally come up with in a
2012 interview with qsr magazine former
McDonald's VP of advertising Roy T
burgled said the original Grimace was
scaly mean-looking had forearms and had
no charm whatsoever in the first ad
campaign he's literally referred to as
the evil
Grimace it was a g day in McDonald Land
because the evil Grimace had grabbed all
the
cups but over the years the character
transitioned into the softer plush two
armed blob that we know today